[Music]
[Applause]
the old bait-and-switch you know it's
never say never kids opportunity
obviously to do a show and it's 20-foot
seas and very special season but also to
do it on the show but we'll see if
that's a blessing or it or a curse I
mean obviously you don't want to bring
too much of it home and we tend to be
competitive but I think at the same time
it's cool to have the kind of support
system to we can we know what each other
is going through a little bit so we can
we can support each other through the
whole process it's TV gold I think I
think there's lots of ways to play up
the story and I think that the dancing
side of it is going to be so interesting
with how we come out and what each
couple is going to bring and how they're
going to be different I said I would
never do this show but then I you know
you find yourself thinking how can I
tell my five-year-old you know don't be
don't be scared to go out for baseball
don't be scared to try tennis lessons
Winnie by myself I'm not practicing the
kind of what I'm preaching so you know I
was like you know what I've never really
been a big dancer always been a little
bit scared of it but that's probably all
the worried you know reason more to be a
part of the show and hopefully the kids
will enjoy it hopefully but they won't
play favorites to mama and daddy will
get some love too but it'll be fun I'm
getting advice on Vanessa like every day
and she's been great to talk to it's
like the old barter system we're trading
parenting advice for dance lessons
our babies are two three weeks apart shy
and Phoenix are born literally just
weeks apart and it's a it's a beautiful
journey to be able to go through it with
someone that gets you because it's
deeper than just dancing
what it was you and me to do the song
you know what this is a fun opportunity
for us to add another layer to our
relationship we've been together for 10
years we have three kids under five
years old and the opportunity to do
something for each other as well as for
ourselves individually I mean already
I've been training for two weeks and I
feel better than I've ever felt in my
life I mean I have more energy I feel my
salmon is getting better I feel like I
just might you know mix 43 I'm 36 and we
got three kids that want to wrestle and
play around all day and this is actually
kind of training me to be a better mommy
so thanks to have another daddy standing
here with me thank you married couple
but first time married couple has been
partnered with Miriam I love this
partnership I think is gonna be great
just because I know what I think she
needs you know I mean in within all the
stuff that's going on in their household
and so you know I understand timing
understand schedule from today it's
gonna be two and a half whatever months
of just non-stop 24/7 thinking about
your cha-cha I promise you dad trust me
I've already I've caught myself in the
bathroom I'm like brushing my teeth or
holding the baby and that Nick is in it
is it on the other weird
sure what is it
I mean like ya think it's like he might
become a hashtag I think maybe like I
know Shay skis probably what she's new
already of somebody to family at home I
know so now one of us has to or we're
never gonna hear the end of this and
Thanksgiving dinner
we just hope we want to get to the
finals all four of us get to the finals
and then apparently that's when they say
the gloves come off but whatever if all
four of us get there
[Music]